brexit the playful fun name that's been
given to a disaster he's like if you
said an animal died of auto-erotic
asphyxiation it's cute although when you
think about the actual consequences it
becomes quite sad it has now been two
and a half years since Britain voted to
leave the EU the long story short of it
is there was a bus with the lie on its
people made a massively consequential
decision by a narrow margin and ever
since the subject of the impending
brexit has dominated every waking moment
in British life it even comes up on
reality shows like this one called love
island what do you think about Breck sir
but leaving the European Union as
seriously don't have so like if you so
it was to leave the EU so we welfare and
like things we trade with would be cut
down so does that mean we won't have any
cheese doesn't it mean it would be odd
to like go to like Spain and store shall
be hard to go on holidays yeah I think
so I love my holidays yeah ok so there's
a lot to unpack there absolutely none of
which is worth unpacking it's not coming
over to help our friends move and
finding all these boxes are labeled dead
spiders for mommy yeah you could unpack
that but it's probably better to just
burn everything to the ground and never
speak of it again the point is you
cannot escape talk about brexit in the
UK it's something brilliantly captured
by a TV show they're called goggle box
it's a show in Britain where you get to
watch other people watch TV it's
actually great trust me just eavesdrop
on some British people watching the news
why did David Cameron car referendum in
the first place he should be in prison
Britain want to have the cake and eat it
they want to trade with the rest of the
world but they'll also have the benefit
of trading with Europe I am halfway
through the 585 page withdrawal
agreement
oh it's like one of those monks I saw in
Pusey Mary different day same old
Mary I took Mike you swear I saw it on
the mug I'm just quoting what I read on
the mug okay
here's something else I saw in a mug
Mary it said this marriage is like a
locomotive lying on my chest crushing my
spirit to dust I'm just quoting what I
saw at a Marc Barry don't blame me blame
the mug people in Britain are completely
exhausted by brexit talk and the crazy
thing is it hasn't even happened yet
although it has already had big effect
on the British economy in the wake of
the brexit vote the UK has become one of
the worst performing economies in the g7
major companies like Nissan and Dyson
are moving operations out of Britain and
the pound has dropped by almost 14
percent and all of this will come to a
head just 40 days from now on March 29th
when the UK is set to officially leave
the EU and it could be an absolute
catastrophe because nothing is happening
the way that was promised Britain was
supposed to leave the EU in orderly
stages first entering a transition
period on March 29th during which it
would negotiate its future relationship
with the EU and then leave entirely and
Prime Minister Theresa May has spent the
last two years locking down the terms of
that transition plan with the EU but
when she presented this agreed-upon deal
to Parliament this happened Theresa May
suffers the biggest Commons defeat in
history this was the moment the defeat
was announced the eyes to the right 202
the nose to the left
432 what was that noise there that was
the biggest college defeat in British
history and they sounded like a middle
school lunchroom we've just heard
someone call to the principal's office
Oh Teresa's in trouble
now it's lovely we can't show that
moment in the UK because of their stupid
law banning parliamentary footage in
comedy show so when this show airs there
tomorrow night it will be replaced by a
clip from a 1983 Chippendales exercise
video instead with absolutely no
explanation so this is what they will
see this was the moment the defeat was
announced
that's what they'll get they'll be
confused by it and it will be all their
fault
now the point is the defeat of Teresa
Mays deal raised the specter of what
many consider to be the worst case
scenario here the UK dropping out of the
EU next month with no transition plan in
place it's the so-called No Deal
scenario and the ramifications of that
could be massive not just for the UK or
the EU but for the entire world so
tonight let's try and answer a few
questions why don't people like Teresa
Mays deal what happens if the UK leaves
with no deal and could they just not do
brexit at all and let's start with why
parliament rejected her deal there's a
lot of reasons that people don't like it
but the biggest sticking point has to do
with Northern Ireland and let me explain
here you see the UK is actually four
countries England Scotland Wales and
Northern Ireland a Fab Four sort of like
the Beatles I won't say who the Ringo is
because that would be unfair to Wales
now not that Northern Ireland shares a
border with the Republic of Ireland and
right now everything you see here is
part of the EU so Goods and people can
move freely between them but the whole
point of brixon is for the UK to leave
the EU and that could put a hard border
across Ireland and that could be a big
problem in a region that has been
plagued by sectarian violence and I
don't have time to get into the
socio-political history of Ireland right
now so feel free to google IRA bombings
or Bloody Sunday or Daniel day-lewis is
1990s film output or do you know what do
you know what I'll just let the
cranberries sum it all up in about 10
seconds
[Music]
that's basically it tanks bombs guns
absolutely no more than four cords you
know Island now in the troubles
thousands of people died businesses on
the board that were regularly bombed and
checkpoints became targets so removing
them was a centerpiece to the historic
Good Friday Agreement of 1998 which
brought a fragile peace to the whole
region
returning to checkpoints in any way
shape or form is going to re-inflate
tensions as people who live there know
somebody builds our customs pushed and
the border between the north and
southern ireland people will shut out
and the shoot that the people who work
in it that's absolutely 100% certainty
Wow that is striking because normally
for people to be that certain that
something will be a disaster
they need to see Will Smith in blue face
so everyone here agrees there cannot be
a hard border there again but how do you
avoid that because if you are not in the
EU goods have to be screened somewhere
like you would at any international
border and no one is yet come up with a
plausible solution for this some
including former foreign secretary an
untitled Gary Busey project Boris
Johnson have proposed elaborate work
around including technologies that don't
yet exist and custom screenings near but
not at the border but Ireland is not
remotely convinced by those and when
journalists pushed Boris Johnson for
more details on this his response did
not inspire confidence nobody thinks
it's a realistic plan because they don't
think eyelid would accept the EU don't
don't don't run away we want to ask you
some serious questions because you've
just done a load of interviews why don't
you torch Anna for an answer
answer a couple of questions you could
this is absurd you ought to have a
serious conversation about breakfast or
then you ride on why can't you answer
any serious questions I'll tell you why
Boris can't answer any serious questions
he doesn't have any answers in fact the
only question he's ever capable of
answering is what would it look like if
Gordon Ramsay was tumble dried on high
so so just in case no one comes up with
a solution for this unfixable problem by
the end of the transition period the EU
and Teresa may agreed on something
called a backstop now under it
Northern Ireland would broadly live
under EU rules and there would be a hard
border between it and the rest of the UK
and that would remain in effect until
they came up with a permanent solution
to the border problem a solution that
remember does not exist the problem is
brexit ears have strong reservations
about the backstop and they want to
resume to renegotiate it but the EU says
that they are done negotiating leaving
Britain hurtling towards the ever
increasing possibility of leaving next
month with no deal in place at all so
what happens if there is no deal well
first ironically there will be a hard
border in Ireland the one thing that
everyone agrees they don't want but the
consequences would go much further than
that because it won't just be the Irish
border where there will be customs
checks brand-new screenings will be
required at every point of entry and at
major British ports like Dover where
trucks arrive on ferries that could mean
chaos under No Deal breaks in World
Trade Organization rules would kick in
overnight
meaning customs inspections on every
vehicle by one estimate if customs
delayed each truck by just seventy
additional seconds the wait to board the
ferry could reach six days yeah and
that's a problem because the whole
system is built on seamless movement
introduce any hitch into that system and
it all breaks down is like we in a
supermarket checkout when one person
brings a fruit that the cashier doesn't
know hold on a second you are not trying
to buy a dragon fruit at a Kroger at
6:00 p.m. on a rainy Sunday you get the
outta here
any personal goods will be particularly
hearted by delays at ports as this
flower importer will tell you if things
get delayed as shipping gets delayed and
we're trade and weed no no no flowers so
you know we need free movements and it
will affect us what's at stake for you
if we don't get this right everything my
family my house yeah we've been trading
for 33 years yeah that's very sad
because people do tend to want flowers
now and alive although you might
actually feel slightly less sorry for
that man when you hear what he said next
yeah we've been trading for 33 years and
I did vote to leave do you regret that
are definitely up second thoughts now
but but when you voted leader do not
think well this is gonna affect my
family I didn't really think about it
like that I didn't really think about
the business side of it yeah well you
probably should have done Samia and now
you have pretty much yourself
with a rusty piece of rebar which isn't
offensive it's something I saw in a mug
sell it's fine the math makes it okay
Mary
now look the selling prospect of a No
Deal brexit has now become likely enough
that the government has released over a
hundred guidance documents instructing
people about what to do if it does
happen everything from how pesticides
will be regulated to what the new
procedures would be for taking your
horse abroad although I think I can
actually solve that one for you right
now take off its shoes put it in a
separate trade and look innocently
confused when airport security starts
asking whose horse this is and
well some of what will happen in a No
Deal scenario may go into the category
of manageable annoyance there are some
genuinely alarming issues like will
there be a shortage of medication that
comes from other countries that could
affect someone like this girl with
cerebral palsy and epilepsy
she has three drugs that she has are
critical and without them she will have
multiple seizures in a day it's one of
the biggest countries in the world
financially and I'm sitting here
thinking will I be able to get medicines
in two months time it's a completely
crazy situation yeah you're right about
that because medicine shortages are not
a problem that Britons expect to deal
with they're used to having their
problems limited to hearing Americans
mispronounced the word vitamin not
having enough beans as part of your
breakfast and having to wait 20 years
for another royal wedding how are you
still single George
settle down already you have this many
find a fiancee crush - ferocious lead
already frightening enough there are
warnings of empty shelves and some
Britons have begun stockpiling food or
buying so-called brexit boxes which when
you see what's actually inside them
seems pretty grim they may look like
tins of paint but they could be dinner
alla brexit every brexit box contains
all you need to whip up family favorites
like chili con carne chicken tikka and
even fajitas now putting aside how
unappetizing a paint can of wet meat
sounds let's also not overlook the
metaphorical significance of every dish
in the brexit box being something that
came to Britain from another country and
greatly improve the lives of everyone
there now things look dire here under
any form of brexit Britain's economic
options are basically bad and worse the
government's own analysis suggests that
under a brexit like Teresa Mays plan the
UK economy could be up to 3.9 percent
smaller after 15 years which sounds bad
until you learn that under a No Deal
brexit we're looking at an economy as
much as 9.3 percent smaller and a
slowdown like that would not just hurt
Britain it would ripple across the
entire world and yet incredibly some in
Britain remained completely unfazed by
all this drawing confidence from the
worst possible examples I lost a
grandfather in the first world war I
lost an uncle in the second world war
and we survived you not a little bit
concerned that we're talking about this
political event the same way that we're
talking about the aftermath of world
wars no I'm not I think it's the same
sort of situation but it isn't though is
it because the world wars were provoked
they were a response to outside events
brexit is something that Britain has
done to itself Britain is basically
Pompey if Pompey had voted for the
volcano a gas said the volcano would be
good I believe the bus and a mug backed
it up you trust mugs
and this brings us to the final question
here if all of this is going to be so
bad could Britain just not do this to
which the answer is technically yes
in December the European Court of
Justice ruled that the UK can simply
revoke its intention to withdraw that is
a big indication that Europe would take
Britain back and an even bigger
indication is the existence of the
reunion boys a touch a Dutch group who
described themselves as a boyband driven
to reunite Great Britain with the EU and
if you think if you think they didn't
make a music video you clearly don't
understand why I'm bringing this up
[Music]
don't I mean it's the classic boy baton
formula isn't it you get five Eurotrash
hunks you dress - like fisherman - like
guys who run a VC firm and one like a
Marxist guerrilla with a throat colds
you put the one the world's greatest
danke speech and you have them crooning
different keys about the dissolution of
a customs union
it's just textbook look if I'm honest
that clip does not make a completely
airtight case for staying in the EU but
the rap break certainly does we're
British people know about us is that we
all have spectacular abs look why not
obviously amazing the Queen's are
completely insane so why don't you take
your little euros on four-pack and hit
the gym pencil neck and while clearly
that band is a pretty solid argument for
leaving the EU on any terms necessary
what if Britain did want to stay how
would that even happen
well Teresa may and Parliament could
weigh the evidence and decide that
brexit is not worth it that would be the
truly courageous thing to do they won't
do it because of the political backlash
that they get for defying the popular
will but that is that is why some have
suggested a second referendum now that
would not be easy
first the shortest estimate of the time
it would take to organize a vote is 22
weeks and there's just six weeks left
and also what exactly would people vote
on would it be remain in the EU versus
tourism-based brexit or remain versus
the No Deal brexit or do you put all
three options on the ballot probably
split the vote fail to get a clear
majority for any option and somehow make
this whole mess even worse because the
reality is this situation is far too
complex for an up-or-down referendum
which by the way was also true of the
first one
when voters were just asked to leave or
stay without a sense of what that might
actually mean that the first referendum
was a terrible idea because it was the
government punting a difficult decision
to the people which in the people's
defense is not their job they elect
politicians to make reasoned fact-based
decisions on their behalf
that's how representative democracy
works and you know who could have told
you all of this at the time the people
of goggle box just watch them react to
the referendum being announced in 2016
do you think everybody now is enough to
be to be able to vote cause god that I
know there must be other people like me
this is what's worrying me I'm worried
that people aren't on something that I
don't really truly understand right that
is an intelligent thing to say sometimes
you don't know stuff so you hire someone
else to know it for you if you came to
your doctor with stomach pain and he
said well what do you think should your
appendix leave or remain you probably
say don't ask me do your job
look I of political courage at this
point wouldn't be to call for a second
referendum something that Theresa Mays
already said that she won't do it will
be to acknowledge that the first one was
fatally flawed and that carrying it out
will do long-term damage to the country
and then canceling brexit altogether but
it seems that there is no way that
that's going to happen instead Britain
seems determined to step firmly down
upon the rake of history and suffer the
consequences and I wish I could offer
you a rousing Churchillian speech now
about how everything's going to be okay
but under the circumstances honestly the
best I can offer you is this
people of Britain throughout history
we've faced our share of dark hours the
Great War the Blitz and that time when
Deborah accidentally used Howard's
custard in her own trifle
that's my question Oh No and through all
this a stiff upper lip has prevailed
because this country is not returning
not when other countries have tried to
destroy us and not when we're in the
midst of trying to destroy ourselves and
I know some are yelling Britain come
back don't do this your purchase Lee
yourselves and to them we say oh
we have not even begun to ourselves
we shall ourselves at the ports
we shall ourselves in the shops
result ourselves in the hospitals
and in the fields wizard never surrender
in the dust clears watts will remain
Britain not the same britain certainly a
worse one with a weaker economy possibly
no fresh fruit and a great deal of
confusion over how horses can go on
holiday but written nonetheless once
we've delivered this mortal wounds to
ourselves we will savor the taste of
victory the victory the case night mummy
faith chicken fajitas
[Applause]